[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining today
my name is stephanie whitlin i am one of
the admissions officers at the stanford
graduate school of business and i'm
excited to
be here today and join the rest of the
panelists
in our webinar on your journey from
stanford to the east coast so today
we're going to spend probably the next
50-ish minutes or so learning a little
bit about
their experience the panelists
experience from stanford to the east
coast and they are here to help answer
any questions you might have as it
relates to even their experience at the
gsb and what they're pursuing now
and i do want to take this opportunity
to
elaborate on the importance of our
global community and that we do have
students and alumni especially alumni
all over the world um we have over 60
regional clubs
and
over 30 000 alumni who live globally so
it is a broad network but i think more
importantly beyond the numbers it's
about the tight-knit community
and the deep connections that those
networks provide folks in various
regions all over the world so you can
see many of the different interest
groups that we offer our students
in ways in which you can get engaged
now i'll take some time to
introduce you to our panelists who have
joined us here today
i will ask that at this point we can um
all of you who are here feel free to
unmute yourself and go on video
and i think it probably makes the most
sense for us to start an alpha order and
it looks like carolyn is still probably
trying to join in unless i don't have
this open enough so maybe there are more
okay
all right so we'll start with you jb if
you could just do a brief introduction
um tell us a little bit about you know
where where you were prior to joining
the jsb and what you've been doing since
you graduated
okay yeah so um it's all written down
here but i went to harvard undergrad
moved to los angeles and worked in
hollywood but in the television industry
so they uh talented the creative arts
agency and then a production company
um before joining the gsb
and then after joining the gsb i worked
in consulting for a while at boston
filthy group um in los angeles before i
moved to philadelphia and now i am at
comcast
working in their corporate corporate
strategy
[Music]
all right happy happy to be here thank
you thank you for being online today we
appreciate it
all right and then now thanks for
joining us welcome
hi happy to be here
um yeah so i
i went to brown undergrad i was a
political science major i then spent two
years working at a boutique consulting
firm in boston um where i got really
interested in consumer goods and the
retail space generally transitioned into
a post-consulting role at ross dress for
last it's a national off-price retailer
where i did corporate strategy for four
years uh before the gsb and then while i
was at the gsb i did my summer
internship at el machias which is a
luxury direct to consumer makeup brand
and i rejoined them when i graduated
this spring and i'm now helping um
helping do a performance marketing and
building out a performance marketing
team for a new product launch
great very exciting thanks for joining
us as well
and then finally sasha welcome and
thanks for being here uh we would talk
at this about being alumni but clearly
you're still in the throes of your
educational experience so i think you'll
also have a great perspective to share
with the with the group
of course thanks for having me i
actually started out with nell's class
and so hey good to see you again uh i'm
graduating class of 2022 because i'm a
dual degree with the harvard kennedy
school and so that means my program is
two degrees in three years
i went to carnegie mellon for undergrad
and then pursued a career at goldman
sachs where i worked in investment
management i helped run a foundations
and endowments team
so we invested on behalf of foundations
and endowments
because i have two summers last summer i
worked on my own company so i launched a
company part of the both the chan
program which is an amazing program that
stanford now offers and then this summer
i'm doing venture capital at paypal
ventures so happy and then i'm
not from new york i'm from providence
rhode island but i will be back in new
york post school and i'm in new york now
great wonderful well i love that each of
you bring
a different perspective to the room in
terms of your experiences and i think
that'll be certainly helpful for those
that are online today to um learn from
you
so um
let's first start with in the case of
jb for example who you have at least
been out for a couple years um if you
could just walk us through
sort of your journey and exploration in
terms of pursuing a career path and
maybe talk a little bit more about how
you did land in philadelphia and and
maybe what resources were available to
you as you were exploring that
oh you're on mute sorry
happens to the best of us
exactly uh we we use teams
here so
stop getting used to zoom um yeah so
i guess i'll start with undergrad and go
through that really quickly up to gsb
because i think that's an important part
of this the overall story um i funny
enough i ended up doing consulting after
gsb but in undergrad i want to do
consulting or banking and wanted to
follow what my pat whatever my passion
was and that's what had me move out to
los angeles to follow that hollywood
dream and work in entertainment and
landed me in television um and i did
that for a number of years so a number
of tech companies who are now firmly in
the tv space joined television uh the
industry and was trying to figure out
like why are they doing this like
there's something i don't know because
it doesn't make any sense from my
perspective uh the tv business was
changing a lot so that was sort of made
sense to go to business school at that
time knowing i could always go back
um
very fortunate to get into stanford and
we can talk about that too i'm sure but
um
when i once i got to stanford i wanted
to have flexibility to figure out things
because tv in la is such a niche
industry and that's what had me thinking
about consulting because consulting
gives you flexibility to still figure
things out um
and that was very top of mind got into
bcg i did bcg was that pcg right now
right after business school and moved to
los angeles what actually brought me to
philadelphia was i
got married and we were having a baby
and we wanted to move back east and
consulting offers flexibility so we
could pick any city we wanted just about
as long as a bcg office and there
happened to be a bcg office in
philadelphia and real estate is very
affordable in philadelphia especially
compared to new york and dc um so that's
what that's what made philadelphia make
sense um and that i knew in the back of
my mind comcast was in philadelphia and
someone who had been interested in tech
and maybe want to go back to media or
entertainment comcast owns nbc universal
even last space in new york so like
philadelphia sort of made sense because
i still wasn't completely sure what i
wanted to do um now i'm in corporate
strategy at comcast which is
like very similar to consulting but do
different projects
for mdc for comcast cable for sky which
is based in europe um and i'm still very
much trying to figure out what i want to
do though it's
probably going to be somewhat something
back in the media space um so
long-running answer but i hope i
answered the question there
yes no thank you very much and i'm sure
folks will have follow-up questions for
you
um
let's see here um sasha i wanted to talk
a little bit about your journey and
maybe even how you explored pursuing a
joint or dual degree um and what your
thought process was like for those who
may be considering that um and also just
how you decided between you know wanting
to pursue both
hks and the gsb
sure
initially the plan was only to get an
mba
one of the reasons i wanted to get an
mba is because i'd been in one company
in one industry my whole entire career
and i had a different role every two
years but still i knew there was a lot i
didn't know and stanford was a great fit
for me in terms of being a playground
where i could kind of explore my
interests
without
with no pressure really just explore
what would make sense for me and so i
went to gsb and then started to realize
i had this big gap which was the policy
side and i really enjoy government i
enjoy talking about policy
different aspects of policy when it
comes to business and so decided to
apply to the kennedy school
stanford is phenomenal once you get in
in terms of helping you figure out how
to do both and there's so much
flexibility
and the two have been very complimentary
i'm very glad i'm doing them they're
very different degrees but very much go
hand in hand
great
thank you thanks so much for elaborating
a bit
and yes carolyn hi welcome thanks for
joining us um
i had to slide up earlier um with your
panelist information but if you wouldn't
mind taking a moment to introduce
yourself um let us know a little bit
about you know what you did pre pre-gsp
and where you're at now um and
anything else you'd like to elaborate on
so well sure yeah it's great to be with
you today sorry for some major technical
difficulties
um and a maiden name to married name
change which i think caused some
confusion
but i am carolyn farley i'm a partner
with arbor view capital we are a growth
equity impact focused firm based in
washington dc
before the gsb i was actually in south
africa for four years um also in impact
investing um but at an earlier stage so
i i spent two years as an operator with
an uh education startup and then two
years
in uh impact venture capital
thank you thanks for being here
sure it's a pleasure
um so what we'll do is i see a couple
questions in um
the chat um nell i think this might be
one for you to answer but i encourage
anyone who has anything to add to share
uh so june has a question about coming
from a non-traditional background she's
worked as a
fashion designer
years apple tommy hilfiger and book
brooks brothers she wants to learn about
what kinds of opportunities stanford has
to offer candidates like her or those
coming from a non-traditional background
especially as she's interested in
transitioning into the retail or
consumer space and finance
so might you especially given your
background be able to give some uh you
know insights and anyone else that wants
to chime in feel free to do so
sure and i'm getting an internet
unstable notification so please if i
break up just you know continue on
without me and if that does happen
you're welcome to take your audio off
that has a lot so it might be easier and
then i'm sorry your video off yeah we
can just listen to the audio yeah that's
great
uh so yeah i uh it's funny i guess i'm
classified as a non-traditional although
i did have a little bit of consulting
background but coming straight from
retail i think is slightly a different
um background than than many other
candidates
i guess a couple ways of answering the
question
one is just as someone who didn't come
from a very significant quant background
there are a lot of resources early on
when you get to the gsb
helping you sort of get up to speed on
business basics and fundamentals to help
you
essentially set you up for better
success as you progress into the
interview process and if you're doing
formalized recruiting and finance as an
example that would be really critical so
so those were i think just very helpful
in terms of getting up to speed and
getting some business fundamentals under
my belt as i you know moved along in the
curriculum
um
and then in terms of pivoting into sort
of
consumer or retail and
i didn't come at it from a lens of
wanting to get into per consumer within
the finance space but really i would say
any background i think is um
can can bring a lot of value to the
industry and so i already came from the
retail space but i spent a lot of my
time early on networking with folks who
were the class ahead of me in the
consumer and retail club and honestly
that initial outreach i did was how i
ended up at el machias just a kind of
chance encounter with someone who
interned there the summer before who
ended up becoming sort of like a mentor
friend figure to me at the gsb was sort
of the path that that led me into the
conversations that opened up the door
for the internship so i guess um kind of
two answers is basically there are
plenty of resources for non-traditional
candidates to get up to speed on
business fundamentals not to mention how
amazing the career center is um grace in
particular who kind of focuses on the
retail
uh vertical is absolutely one of the
most well-connected people i've come
across at the gsb and not saying
something and she just kind of sends you
a litany of different emails and people
that you can reach out to in the
consumer space and then on top of that i
would say that consumer and retail club
is an absolutely amazing group pretty
tight-knit group of people because it's
not a huge pathway that that folks take
at the gsb um and so very eager to help
and and connect you with with people in
their network so i'm also happy to you
know answer any specific questions about
consumer retail sort of offline um if
that's helpful
yeah thanks now you bring up a big
a good point which is being able to
capitalize and leverage the resources
and
time effort that all of the
advisors at the career management center
offer to students so regardless of
whether you plan to
you know pivot your career
after the gsb or you stay in the same
path that you've been in they offer
lots of opportunities both from advising
as well as a self-directed job search
opportunities and networking and lots of
connections so that's very true
um
one question peter brought up in the um
q a was um if the panel could comment on
how the gsb has either helped them hone
in on their career vision and path and
or broaden their horizons
uh
sort of when i hear that i think of the
the course that the career management
center offers on um
you know career visioning uh but i'd
love to hear from some of you have
either used those resources or other
things to help you hone in on that
does anyone want to start that
conversation
yeah i can i can talk about um
i i think i'm still very much developing
my vision but i can talk about the
broadening my horizons perspective and
my time at the gsb
at the gsp and even after since i've
left as i'm talking to classmates um
have continued to be broadened i came to
gsb knowing i wanted to do consulting
because i wanted that flexibility so i
was pretty tunnel vision in that sense
um
but as i've talked to
other classmates about just like what
like venture capital and what like i
didn't
explore as much at the gsp but like now
that i'm working in tragedy thinking
looking at startups even in my current
role like wow that's actually a very
very cool
industry to be in
and it might actually work for me and i
might find it interesting interesting
and what i've been able to do with the
gsb is still talk to the career advisors
you get you get free coaching sessions i
think like three of them um so i'm
talking to them i'm talking to my
classmates uh developing a perspective i
don't know if this is necessarily what i
want to do but it's definitely like oh
this could be an option and um
it could make sense for me and i again
still figuring out what i want to do but
it's it's definitely broadened that
horizon and something that would not
have come hadn't come to mind um had it
been out for the jsp in the community
yeah yeah i think you bring up a good
point the career management center is
not just a resource you use as a student
but one that you have for your lifelong
career and being able to take advantage
of that is wonderful so i'm glad that
you've done that um
carolyn did you want to jump in yeah i'd
also be happy to add um kind of on the
theme of career enhancement and um
advancement i guess i came into the gsb
pretty sure of what i wanted to do
afterwards i've been
an operator and an investor in impact
investing and just knew that i loved
that space
um
but i'd also been in south africa for
four years and so making the geographic
transition back to the us
and
understanding the landscape of impact
investing across the u.s was very
different when i'd left
in
the very beginning of 2013 impact
investing was just a much more mason
industry and in the years i'd been gone
it had developed significantly
and so being able to leverage the
speakers and the
professor connections while i was on
campus
in order to meet a ton of different
people and really get a feel for myself
for the landscape of impact investing
and then also to be in a cohort of
classmates that are all really purpose
driven whether that means they're going
to go on to be entrepreneurs or
consultants or investors or other kinds
of operators
it just meant that i now have when i'm
looking at new in investment
opportunities
this cohort of people to reach out to to
rely on for subject matter expertise um
for deal structuring uh for a whole
variety of support um and it's it's
really enhanced my career
thank you
thank you anything else for nell or
sasha that you want to add or
did they kind of touch on that
the one thing i'll add is
so a few things a my husband is also a
gsb alum and he we were based in new
york he moved out to the bay with me uh
you know for the two years and even then
the career center was very helpful in
helping him negotiate his offer
helping him figure out how to transition
uh as an so in his own career and so
that was amazing to see and then the
second thing i'll say is i came to the
gsb not quite knowing what i would do
next i ended up in venture capital which
was the last place i imagined myself
being in uh but it actually the job came
from talking to an alum and the
conversation was more around hey i want
to be an operator this is what i'm
thinking and they look at me and they're
like hey you should actually consider
venture capital and i got the job after
a 20-minute conversation i kid you not
it was probably the third conversation i
had for recruiting um and so i in that
sense that people are just very real and
very good at helping you parse out where
you'd be a good fit
that's a great point
um all right well let's certainly you've
been able all of you in one way shape or
form to broaden your horizons or
leverage the resources available um can
you talk a little bit about well let's
do this first
for those of you who
have returned sasha i know you're still
completing your degree but we'll
encounter and still returning to the
east coast post gsb um for how many of
you were was it intentional like or
you know you plan to do it so nell yes
sasha okay
jb maybe or for which of who
whom uh was it more
serendipitous or unplanned
yeah okay okay so for the intentional
ones was there anything sasha nell i
know jb sort of would either of you
speak to how you went about going
or going about that because i think
that's one of the things that many of
our prospective candidates think about
is if i land at the stanford gsb on the
west coast am i committed to staying out
there what's the opportunity to
you know move to the east coast and what
sort of um
resources will be available to me so
um now do you want to start out maybe
talk a little bit about that i know it
hasn't been longer
for
you either but maybe you can speak to
that
yeah sure uh yeah so i
i actually was
i don't say hesitant to accept my gsb
offer because i knew i wanted to but i
was
knew that i wanted to end up back in new
york it's where i'm from my parents are
here my family's here my
significant other is here so i was
definitely i was nervous about moving
cross-country and wanting to make sure
that i was leaving open the door to come
back so when i got to school i sort of
focused a lot of my networking
calls on alums in the consumer retail
space that were based in new york um and
actually the the uh alum who interviewed
me
you know was in the consumer and retail
space in new york city and was like
instrumental in kind of connecting me
with people and and being a resource for
me even as i got to the gsb which just
goes to show you that like
i don't know how strong the you know
connections are within the network that
like the person that interviewed me and
was sort of like um stop gates and
seeing if i even got in ended up like
really helping me along the way which i
thought was cool
and so when i got to school um
i was actually surprised by how many
members of both my class and the class
above sort of had intentions of going
back to the east coast so i didn't feel
like i was in a place where i was an
anomaly that i didn't actually want to
stay in the bay area so um not to say
that i sort of focus only my
conversations on those people but in
terms of networking like i was very
intentional about um having coffee chats
and um you know having conversations
with alums who were who were based east
coast and sort of understanding how they
did it and then i would say like the job
opportunity was serendipitous in that it
was maybe similar to sasha like one of
the first conversations i have ended up
being
checking the boxes on both functional
type of role that i wanted for my summer
internship experience and
in the geographic area um
and so i didn't really explore anything
else beyond that i would say partially
because then covet happened and getting
a job and a growing startup at that
stage and the beauty industry was like
not gonna happen i mean there were a lot
of people hiring at that stage so um
yeah i would say so kind of networking
was intentional and then it i ended up
just sort of seizing an opportunity that
came quickly but um i don't know if it's
happenstance or just my own personal
vantage point but i but i definitely do
get the sense that
within the recent gsb classes they're
skewing like less towards west coast
than they have historically and i
definitely feel like in terms of
representation from like mine and
sasha's class like
there's so many more people that are
back on the east coast than i ever would
have anticipated so um it's not at all a
challenging move to make to end up back
on the east coast if that's where you
want to be
sasha i see you nodding your head so
anything else you want to add and then
i'll go to carolyn who has a different
experience
yeah plus one on everything nell said
for me i was also more relaxed about it
because my husband's class is 20 i'll
call him evan his name is evan uh he's
class of 2013. and so i saw i know evan
yes of course
yeah so i saw his network here like so
many of our close friends are gsb um so
it was never a thing for me to think
that i'd be on the east coast and there
wouldn't be a lot of alums just because
i'd seen it on the other side
gotcha all right and then carolyn for
you where it wasn't necessarily
intentional more serendipity talk a
little bit about that
yeah i'll say um in terms of where some
classmates have landed especially at
this point in time if you a few years
out not far though um there's a really
strong cohort in new york and there's
probably half a dozen of us in dc that
have just for my class alone that's been
a wonderful
community and landing place
and then the other piece that's been a
really good part of my dc experience has
been there's an organization that's
called gsb women's circles and it
connects intergenerational women alumni
from gsb
uh and
i think there are nine women in my
circle we meet once a month and it's
such a wonderful way to stay connected
to the experience that we had on campus
and some of the deeper questions that we
ask ourselves while we're there
um and uh and just you know i'm uh
having my first child in a in about a
month and um we had a baby shower
together and the
experience and support um the
intergenerational factor of this circle
has been really a wonderful part of the
experience
oh i'm glad to hear that and
congratulations jb clapping because um
we learned he just welcomed a little
girl into the world in may
so you're in good company jb when you i
know philadelphia well you moved either
pre-pandemic and then the pandemic
happened so it's been
and you had a baby by the way and all of
this um so what have been the outlets if
any that you've used to stay connected
or what kind of advice might you give
individuals who are explain exploring
other smaller markets on the east coast
for example
yeah i guess the first thing i'll say is
you might be surprised with gsbears i i
just remember this people are talking
the reason i got into comcast was
because i reached out to someone i
looked up i saw an opening and i was
like i don't know anyone at comcast let
me
look up comcast and like someone popped
in and was like xbcg xg gsb and worked
in hr so i was like i guess this person
i should reach out to this person so
gs beers are all over all over the place
and philly is not the biggest market in
general um
but
the reason
i we decided to come here is i knew the
flexibility of hey it's a short train
ride to new york um and that's always or
dc and so there's always a possibility
and we're not um necessarily stuck in
stuck in philadelphia if you can't find
something um but but to answer the
question like outlets i'm
so connected with my
everyone from the gs um from the gsb my
friends in new york and my even the ones
still in san francisco um talking to
them very often i think the pandemic
just made this whole digital because
we're all locked down for a year it
didn't even feel um like i was in a
different except for the time difference
didn't really feel like i was in a
different place because everyone was
stuck at home anyway uh so stayed
connected via
um via zoom and um
and everything with them uh and i i
think like
doing that and then just trying to find
your community where you are at because
people
are people are there uh been a little
bit more difficult for me with the baby
and only starting to like get out of the
house very recently but
um that's what i'm looking to do now
yeah
yeah thank you
um i'm gonna go to a question in the um
q a that jake um put in
um his question is one of the main
reasons that gsb appeals to me and and
frankly probably many candidates is its
focus on developing leaders um
can you on the panel share what you felt
were the most impactful or remember
memorable leadership trainings or growth
opportunities um that you've had or in
some cases are having so i'd actually
love to hear from each of you because
you may have different experiences or um
ways in which you engaged in the
leadership curriculum or other things on
campus i i guess i'll start with sasha
your most recent and still in the thick
of a little little do you want to talk a
little bit about that for you sure yes i
am in the thick of it so i've completed
a year at um stanford and i've also
completed a year at the kennedy school
so i have one more year left and this is
what they call my split year
and
the year that i was at stanford uh
three-fourths of it was in person um and
i'd say there were a few things that
really stood out for me
and it had nothing to do whether it was
in person or not so the first is i
launched
stanford's first conference on digital
currencies and payments
and i actually did that with a professor
that's a that's at stanford that's well
world renowned in the in the area and
actually wrote about him in my ygsb
essay like i really really wanted to
work with him and not only did i get the
chance to work with him but we
built something amazing where we flew in
economists
from the imf and the bank of england and
it was just
really really incredible so that's one
the second is i took a finance class
that i loved um it's called finance 207
it's a governance finance class and i
got to work with that professor to
revamp the whole curriculum
when things went virtual and that was so
cool and fun
ultimately i think i want to be a
professor
at some point in my life and that was an
amazing experience
and then the third thing i'll say is the
people and talk
i did a talk
right before the end of my first year
and it was one of the most amazing
experiences i've ever had it was an
opportunity
for me to show up as my whole self in a
way i hadn't ever before in my life
and i built really close relationships
not because of that but in addition to
that
and so those those are probably the
three highlights
even i do that um thank you for sharing
it i do wish you the best on your
journey to um pursue professorship or
teaching in some way shape or form in
your career i'm gonna work um
reverse chronologically so
you're most recent now i'll i'll just go
to nell to see if she has anything to
add as it relates to that developing
leader
or any memorable experience that might
be helpful for folks to hear about
sure i have two kind of quick ones i can
touch on one actually was sparked by by
sasha explaining the kind of the
conference uh i was one of the gala
co-chairs for the gsb gives back gala
which is a
large the largest fundraiser and largest
event that the gsb has every year where
we raise money we raise over a hundred
thousand dollars for charities and put
on a massive kind of like 700 person
event which these days sounds kind of
unvaluable that those actually happened
but uh it actually happened right before
everything went virtual last year for
kovid um
and was just you know i sort of
with a couple of other co-chairs
organized and executed the day of the
you know the actual fest event and we
successfully were able to raise that
money for charities and um
i think just being able to put on an
event like that i mean i have no
experience like party planning event
planning anything like that and being
able to sort of be a representative of
stanford
and sort of organize this huge
culminating celebration for 750 people
was was awesome and also very
challenging i hate sending emails like
big blast emails out to the class and i
sent like probably 15 that night or
something like that so even that was
like a leadership moment for me and then
i would say um
a second one is just touchy feely not
necessarily i would say seen as like a
leadership class it's maybe more of like
an interpersonal
class it's actually called interpersonal
dynamics but i was in a tea group that
was fully virtual during covid and i
just had like an absolutely unbelievable
experience in that setting it didn't
matter that it was virtual and my
biggest learning was kind of how i can
um
come across sometimes like non-verbally
and i had no awareness of of sort of
different things that i was potentially
giving off um and and being able to be
in a group of people that i felt so
comfortable with who are delivering
feedback to me that i can now
action and now i'm running a team for
the first time and being so much more
aware of like non-verbal cues i'm giving
off um
it was was absolutely instrumental to me
and i think will just be a huge
value-added as i as i learned kind of
how to lead a team for the first time
i'm i'm really glad to hear that you
know i haven't had an opportunity to
connect with a lot of the current
students and see how that experience has
been so i'm it's nice to hear that even
in a remote or virtual setting that you
still um got the value out of especially
an experience like interpersonal
dynamics which really focuses so much on
you know wanting to put your full self
forward and still being able to do that
um for either carolyn and jb do you want
to chime in and share anything from your
experience that might have been the most
memorable or impactful in your
leadership journey
sure i'm glad um i'm glad touchy feely
was touched on
because that was one one on my mind but
i'd also say a couple of others so i
you're gonna hear an impact theme here
but um there is an impact fund that the
gsb has which is a really incredible
opportunity um to actually have a pool
of capital that gets invested that um
students lead to invest each year um and
it's completely student run as an
organization and
the sub teams of
um
financial inclusion or energy in the
environment are run by students as well
and so i participated my first year had
a fabulous experience and decided to be
a
a sector leader the second year for
energy and the environment
and then um i also took a class um that
was called that um is taught by heidi
patel and charles ewald called investing
for good uh my first year
loved it um was offered the opportunity
to be a ta a teaching assistant to
heidi and charles in my second year and
it both allowed me to meet the next
generation class um that shared the same
interest area that i do
but also to develop a strong
relationship with both heidi and charles
which was wonderful
um and then the last one there's there's
courses that are amazing for this as
well so like touchy feely there's a
course called
managing difficult conversations and
it's all about putting you in the moment
of a case study and having to play a
role of someone in that case and how
they would have to handle a really
challenging
work conversation
and it gives you the opportunity to
practice those when it's a hypothetical
situation before
at some point in your career you will be
in that
in that challenging situation and have
to take it on the fly
yeah no doubt no doubt those are great
great um
examples and thank you for reminding me
of all the different ways in which you
can get engaged jb to add
yeah this um one thing to to add i
wasn't um so we've talked about the
clubs you can join the classes you can
you can take um i was an arbuckle fellow
um so that means that i took touchy
feely but then you're also a cult in
your second year you're a coach to
either a leadership labs group and also
three um i think it was three three
first years throughout the like the
second and third quarter um
and i will say like the the learning
from having these real conversations and
trying to coach people um in
in of subject areas that you don't know
like one of my coaches was he's doing
his own startup
at gsb in his first year and he's asking
me for advice and you realize like i
can't give advice i just have to help
him think through how to solve problems
because i i don't know the answers and
yes he's gonna know the answers more
than i could um but that that's that was
just such a great program i'm very
fortunate to have gotten into it and the
learning i got from that i've taken it
as like when i became a project leader
at pcg and now and even in my current
role as i have um
younger people who have i'm working with
and trying to like help them in their
careers and give them guidance and such
yeah the arbuckle fellows program is
wonderful and i know it's very popular
and not everyone can do it so i'm glad
you had the opportunity to to really get
involved in that way
um there's one question that actually
this is probably going to go back to
something you said previously carolyn so
um
a comment about your classmates being
purpose driven how often do students
bring up social stakeholder impact when
discussing business decisions
and do these discussions take place
mostly in only like social impact
classes or more broadly if there's
anything you can share there
yeah so one of the things that attracted
me the most to stanford and i think this
has only become more true over the years
was that there are impact-oriented case
studies
across the curriculum even if it's not
specifically an impact class so in a
like 101 kind of accounting class
um
that will be part of the case studies
which i think is really phenomenal so
there's a common language across the
student body whether that's your focus
area or not
and then um when i think about purpose
driven i just i think about how many
different
avenues there are to have purpose in
your career these days like that
i almost use the impact definition with
air quotes um because you can also i
remember there's a
a friend i made at stanford who went
into an operating role at a big fast
food chain
trying to make their supply chain more
sustainable
and that's probably one of the highest
leverage impact roles you can have um
and it's not necessarily designated as
impact
um so i think there are a lot of people
who are asking them these themselves
these questions of how can i have more
purpose and more impact in my life in
whatever field i go into and that i
found really attractive
thank you thanks so much that was
helpful
um
this is this is the part of the session
where people are seeking advice which i
appreciate so the question that
christina poses is knowing what you know
now
would you have done anything differently
in terms of the curriculum or your
experience on campus and then also how
much experience did everyone have before
they applied so we can talk about and
that would be probably years of work
experience um but
let's start first with now who just
graduated and has a few months under her
belt
knowing what you know now and looking
back was there anything that you might
do differently
um yeah
i'm sure there are i think one thing
is that it is very easy to get sort of
consumed by different components of
school um and i don't think i was super
intentional in the first quarter of my
first year around like how i wanted to
be spending my time and i definitely did
a lot of like brown bag lunches that i
had no interest and should not have been
at because there was just like nothing
related to what i wanted to do and i
think i wish i wish i was a little
pickier about like how i was spending my
time early on um and also giving myself
the latitude to like do nothing during
lunch and actually just like sit and
breathe for a second so that's one thing
i think just give yourself some credit
early on that it's a stressful
experience and and you can kind of give
yourself a little breathing room
second is i i don't think i took good
enough advantage just over the course of
the two years i think kovid was a big
part of it but not not an excuse
of like developing close relationships
with professors there are a couple that
i
liked a lot and we had really good
rapport in class and i just i didn't
really push myself often to um
like ask if i could take them to coffee
or like just have a more personal
relationship with them there were a
handful that i did but i think i could
have um probably leaned into that more
and i think those are
you know some of the most valuable
relationships that you can afford to the
gsb are a lot of
lecturers or alumni who have very
fascinating stories to tell you about
their gsb experience um and professors
who are just absolutely experts in the
fields that they're instructing on so
that's probably one thing i wish i did
differently um but otherwise no i mean i
think i i think those are
i think i could probably look back at a
million other things and tell you that i
could have done them differently but in
the in hindsight i'm super thrilled with
how the experience went and um and sort
of proud of the relationships i was able
to forge and challenging myself in like
accounting and finance which i truly
never want to take again so um i think
other than that
probably
all in all a good experience
um i want to speak a little bit just
something you said because you know i've
been at the gsb since 2005 and stepped
out for a little bit when i had my son
but there was always and i know many of
you are probably familiar with the
acronym fomo fear of missing out but it
i believe in the most recent years
there's there's also been the
introduction of jomo which is the joy of
missing out so when you say now for
example you took the opportunity to just
like sit and enjoy your lunch or you
know be able to say no when presented
with lots of opportunities i think that
there's some
uh permission now given for both for
both of those to exist at the gsb
um
sasha i know you're still uh you know
you've had one year you still have an
opportunity to relive some things in
your split year are there any things
that you're
more focused on especially as nell says
you know i wish i had been a little bit
more intentional but you know things in
which you're you're hoping to take
advantage of in your your last year
yeah it's kind of cool because i get to
see my friends
complete their degree and then i still
have a year left
and so that's been great uh so i get to
learn from people like now
i think for me the intentionality point
that nell mentioned really hit home
so when covet hit it kind of forced me
to take a step back and ask myself why
i'm doing things
and i actually stepped down from
leadership positions and a couple of
clubs and instead decided to pick three
things and do them really really well as
opposed to ten things and like having a
you know my hand and everything and um
that's been very helpful for me and has
also allowed me to deepen friendships
within the kind of the three things that
i chose
um so i'd say from time to time you know
when you get overwhelmed just take a
step back and ask yourself why you're
doing what you're doing
that's really good advice
um for the two of you have a few years
under your belt jb carolyn anything now
as you reflect having been you know now
now that i've been out a few years
some sage advice or wise
yeah jb go ahead
i'm laughing because like my advice is a
little bit counter to what was just said
because i was going to say
explore um is what i i guess look
everyone is your own individual path i
was i came in there with very like very
much tunnel vision knew i was going to
do consulting once i got the consulting
offer decided to pick classes that i
felt would help me for consulting in the
future um
and i i wish i had spent more time
exploring uh other just other things
that like i wouldn't have known because
uh i came from such a nice industry
myself
in hollywood and um they're just
different opportunities i just never
thought about until i ended up leaving
gsp and talking to other people um so i
guess like look there's a balance you
have to have of course um of x
exploration but and intentionality it's
different for everyone it depends on
your circumstances but for me i wish i
had done a little bit more exploring um
i think that's a great point because it
is something where for everybody
depending on how you
how and when you're stepping in in your
stage of your career or life path you
might have certain uh goals that you're
trying to
um uncover or discover and so
yes absolutely the gsb is two years of
exploration and take advantage of that
and also um without any type of
intentionality sometimes it can be
difficult to figure that out but that's
also part of the process so everyone
comes in from a different
a different vantage point um carolyn
anything else
i think
when nell said
just having down time for lunch and to
be able to meet whoever comes by
and just
they're like have an open table and
really get to know your classmates that
resonates
strongly with me
um
a little bit of an out but uh
something i'd say you should do there
there are amazing cross-listed classes
and opportunities to take classes at
other schools whether it's the design
school or the policy school
the law school like
that was a real plus for me um and
there's just so many
in some ways that like opens up the
possibilities even more because now you
don't just have to look at gsb classes
you can look at all the other schools
too but it's a it's a really special
opportunity
yeah that is we we didn't really talk
too much about it today but that is
something to take advantage of that you
know you're on the stanford campus and
that gives you the opportunity to
explore so many things whether the law
school the engineering school the school
of medicine um
education there are many ways that you
can get
involved and take
um i believe and if i'm not mistaken
it's still somewhat like 12 to be
applied at any other
school applied to your your degree so
a lot of students do take advantage of
that i know we're coming up on time
um so we only have a few more minutes to
go
um
one of the things that often comes up is
just
advice like less you know sort of
parting words and and things to think
about especially as some of these folks
consider applying you know our round one
deadline is coming up in about a month
so if there's any words of encouragement
um i'll kind of
allow you guys to popcorn this but if
you want to convey any messages to those
who are on today
what might that be as they think about
taking this next step in their journey
i can jump in just super quickly but i
didn't mention this but i was actually a
re-applicant and so i would just say the
the thing i did differently the second
time around was a lot of self-reflection
and like being super authentic in my
essays and i didn't stop for one second
to think about what i thought any school
wanted to hear i just like wrote an
essay that was meaningful to me so just
if you're
thinking about what you should be
writing and things like that um i guess
my words of wisdom are just like
do a lot of soul searching and and come
up with something that if you were to
read it to your friends and family they
would you know think you know this
sounds like now and um i'm like honored
that i got to you know able to write
something that felt like that to me
yeah that's a good piece of advice not
only because it starts the journey of
self-reflection in the application but
is also a really big component of the
experience right your two years and so
it sets the stage
uh jb
yeah i i will say i will second like
second that i
i truly believe the only reason i got
into stanford was because of my what
matters most to me in my essay i spent a
lot of time thinking about that and was
weird oddly proud probably too proud of
like what i put together because i was
like wow this really is me and so much
so that i still look at it and as i'm
trying to figure out how to navigate my
career what i actually like i wrote
about creativity and i'm like yeah wow
like this this piece of paper that
helped me get into stanford um i spent a
lot of time thinking about it still
defines where i want to be and what i
enjoy most when when working so um
right i stay authentic to yourself and
um i still think like where whatever
school you're you do end up in that
school will read that and get the
authentic you and then you will be at
the right place
yeah i just want to be clear you have no
idea how you were admitted
[Laughter]
so that's always
regardless it's the type of exercise as
you said and i think it's really
important to have people understand that
if you do it well regardless of whether
you're admitted it should be something
that speaks to who you are at the core
of
who you are and what impacts your
decisions and i hear it all the time
from alums that they do go back and they
read that
and they use it as a benchmark for
trying to you know guide them in the
decisions they make in their future so
nonetheless it's a good valuable
exercise no matter whether it
got you in or not
um
sasha caroline any lasting parting
thoughts
i'd be happy to add i was um i was on
the like quote-unquote older side i
think i had about seven years of
experience when i when i went to the gsb
and and i found that to be the best for
me i'd had some
um real world management experience of
managing teams i'd had some tough um
investment experiences of you know
relationships with entrepreneurs who i
invested in that were challenging and
helping them to navigate their
challenges and so i felt like i had by
that point
a better sense of what it was that i
wanted out of the experience and to the
to the perspectives we've heard a bit
maybe a bit more reflection on who i was
and where i was coming from
and i sometimes get that question from
people of like am i too late to apply
and i think i had such a rich experience
for the stage that i was at in my life
in my career
that's great it's it's different for
everybody right apply when you're ready
but no one's 100 ready but when you're
like almost there because that's when
you can make the most of it
all right
sasha yeah so two thoughts i echo what
caroline carolyn said i had nine years
of experience
and had just gotten married two months
before i started gsb so i was planning a
wedding and applying to business school
and completely echo everything she said
it was nice to know yourself a little
more and then on the reflection point
that was brought up
i journaled every single day for two
months to write my what matters most to
me in y essay and so by the time that
essay was written
it was like this is who i am as a whole
um and i felt very confident in that and
there's something to me there was
something nice
like i gave it a 100
um and you know how it turns out it
turned out and actually i was deciding
between job offers not that long ago
with a classmate i called the classmate
up and he was like hey does this align
with what you wrote in your
what matters most to you and why essay
and i thought that exercise is very
helpful
that's a great point thank you all i
really appreciate each and every one of
your perspectives today that it was a
great conversation and for those
participants who joined us today i hope
you found value
hearing from
our students and alums um thanks again
for your time everyone sasha jb
now carolyn thanks again really
appreciate it and uh
have a great afternoon and evening
[Music]